Republican Ohio Governor and former
presidential candidate John Kasich
previously voiced support for a path to
legal status for undocumented immigrants
he's with us now from Westerville Ohio
governor good to see you thanks for
joining us thank you good to be with you
do you support president Trump's
decision to put daca in the hands of
Congress to take care of this no I don't
say look can you imagine that we're
taking kids who came here you know with
and nothing to do with the fact that
they were brought here they've become a
very significant part of our society in
fact as we know they have been in
Houston one person has been providing
aid to the people that are in trouble
one of the daca kids actually lost his
life trying to help people and now we
now we're put them in jeopardy imagine
if you were one of them if you were one
of these these young people striving to
be a part of America and to make
something of yourself and all of a
sudden somebody tells you one day you
may be deported to a country you know
nothing about we want them in America so
now you got the Congress has six months
it should be take like six hours to get
this done and the way I think they need
to do it is to get reasonable
Republicans and Democrats from the
middle and build out a solution to this
and what's the solution the simple fact
is they ought to be able to stay here
they ought to have permanent resident
status they ought to be able to stay and
continue to contribute and take this
cloud from over their heads well you get
so amazing tell me about this yeah yeah
let me just say this Tom cotton Senator
Tom cotton was on last hour and once
again it's a finger pointing there's you
know both sides are pointing fingers at
each other you've laid out something
where you said get people in the middle
do you think that there's enough
agreement on both sides that they can
work this out you said it should take
six hours what needs to be done to know
what has happened it's so sorry this is
a simple there's a simple moral issue we
don't want to take these young people
who are part of our of our nation and
just threaten them or ship them out of
our country they're contributors so what
do you do yeah you get reasonable people
not the people on the extremes not the
right or the left on extremes but people
in the middle and build it out it's the
same thing they need to do with health
care
we're the people governor how are those
people where are they they exist there
are many of them down there I'm gonna be
down there this week meeting with a
group called the problem solvers caucus
on healthcare and they are made up of
Republicans and Democrats they're like
common sense normal thinking Americans
they actually exist they ought to just
stand up and tell the extremes to just
either contribute be constructive or go
away I mean think about this this is the
United States of America and we're
putting kids young people who are
contributors in jeopardy this is not the
America that we all love this is a
melting part pot and by the way if the
dreamers want to go somewhere and live
come to Ohio we want all the immigrants
to come to Ohio because we know how much
they contribute to America I wouldn't be
in America if it wasn't for immigration
who knows maybe I'd be the president
Croatia you never know governor speaking
of that middle ground how much how much
room do you think there is for an
independent candidate in 2020 very very
difficult for an independent to run now
if you had a Michael Bloomberg that's
willing to spend ten billion dollars
there's a possibility but look the
political landscape is changing every
second before our eyes and we don't know
what the future is gonna bring the
public is fed up I'm here with a bunch
of people who are doing this shot and I
said what do you think of Washington
they said the only thing we like about
it are the good restaurants so as long
as politicians can't get it together it
opens the door for even more dramatic
change chuckle governors are you gonna
run with John Hickenlooper uh you know
as I said you know they can't even
pronounce the name and they can't put
Hickenlooper and Kasich on a bumper
sticker that just won't work
never governor the president tweeted
yesterday that he would revisit daca if
Congress can't legalize this within the
next six months what do you make of that
do you think it indicates he's having a
second I have no idea I got no I I don't
know but here's what I know if I were
president I would have told those states
let's go to court let's get it on you
are intent on shipping kids out of here
you know these states that wanted to sue
I would have said to him all right sue
me and by the way I'm gonna
expose you for what you are because
you're putting kids at risk I just think
is outrageous that these states were
doing this and putting pressure on and
frankly if I were president I'd tell the
Attorney General put on your best suit
get your suitcase ready we're marching
into court and in the meantime I'd be
meeting with Congress and saying just
fix the law it should take six hours not
six months governor almost every
Republican in Congress voted against the
DREAM Act in 2010 which would have given
many of these undocumented illegal
immigrants a path to citizenship so now
President Trump is essentially asking
them what to reverse themselves and vote
for this nor mates might be the great
opportunity literally and I'm not
kidding you I've made laws I run the
state of Ohio if you build this thing
and get reasonable Republicans and
Democrats at a table and say this is
what we're gonna do we're not going to
talk about border walls we're not going
to talk about comprehensive plan just
saving these kids and making sure they
can stay in America that's it that's all
you do take a piece and if you can get
that done then you can move to the
broader agenda of protecting the borders
and making sure we deal with
comprehensive immigration reform but at
this point in time this is a crisis for
people who are now living on the edge of
their seats saying what am I supposed to
do
are they going to ship me out of the
country that I've come to love and
participate in so yes I'm gonna be down
there with Hickenlooper by the way
talking to these problem solver caucus
which is Republicans Democrats they need
to stand up Nora there are too many
members of Congress who are afraid of
the leaders although Paul Ryan said he
wanted to fix this yeah go fix it get it
done lead all right yeah governor thank
you something mazing we keep hearing
Kasich and Hickenlooper together it's
you you said they didn't fit in a bumper
sticker we just heard you say it again
all right governor thank you for come up
with a bumper sticker we'll talk thank
you for passion appreciate your time